[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator tv
recorded on thursday april the 8th on
this week's show
kenny mccaskill the smp mp will tell us
why
he defected to alex salmon's alba party
and the prime minister has promised
freedom from lockdown after
the 21st of june but what kind of
freedom
will it be all that to come in the next
hour of quality tv
and if you enjoy what we're doing here
at spectator tv why not take out a
subscription
to the spectator magazine itself it's
the fastest growing current affairs
publication
in europe and within its pages and on
our website
you can read all your favorite spectator
tv contributors
will even throw in a bottle of free
spectator
gin if you sign up at spectator dot co
dot uk
slash tv offer or you can just google
spectator gin
that's a subscription of 12 issues for
just 12 pounds
plus a free bottle of gin worth 30
pounds
simple arrhythmic arithmetic will tell
you that's a no-brainer
and as ever a very special thanks to
charles stanley for their continued
support
of the week in 60 minutes charlestown is
one of the uk's
leading welfare management firms one of
the oldest companies
on the london stock exchange we're
delighted to be partners
with them now covert
june the 21st is earmarked as freedom
day
on the roadmap out of lockdown even
nightclubs are to reopen
legal requirements on social distancing
should go
and thanks to the uk's successful
vaccine rollout
more than a semblance of pre-covered
normality
beckons or does it is the government
changing the goal posts already
is june the 21st still
a freedom day and a serious hurdles
to the continued rollout of the oxford
astrazeneca jab
emerging which could spook government
ministers further
kate andrews is our economics
correspondent editor of our daily
lunchtime briefing
it's the only roundup email you need for
the latest covered news
you can sign on uh via our website as
she pens this week's cover pieces
headlines
road map to nowhere kate joins us now
okay what's happened this uh
june the 21st day is not as bankable for
end of lockdown anymore is it
sadly no longer when the prime minister
laid out his road map it very much
seemed like the 21st of june was freedom
day the day that you'd be able to go
back to a nightclub
go to a mass event not have any uh cap
on the numbers of people who could
gather together but in truth
they left the really difficult decisions
for separate reviews
around social distancing international
travel returning to work
and potentially bringing in vaccine
passports and we got the teaser this
week of their initial thinking in some
of these areas
and the suggestion was we don't know
when social distancing may lift
despite telling us for months that
vaccine passports were off the table
michael go said that he didn't know
anybody in government including himself
that was thinking
about vaccine passports a few months ago
now he's the one leading the charge to
bring them in
it very much looks like they're on the
cards and if we don't have normal social
distancing by the time we hit the summer
if we're having to use biosecurity
guards cards to access
events to access the pub they haven't
ruled hospitality out by the way
and i think a lot of people will say
well that's not the normal that we
thought we were promised
that is not the full return of our
freedoms it would seem
that liberty is becoming conditional on
doing very specific things that the
government is asking you to do
and there was always a concern that when
we signed them away to tackle the
pandemic
to go into lockdown to save lives that
they wouldn't come rushing back
and despite the roadmap going ahead and
i'm sure many people are looking forward
to
being able to get a haircut or have a
pint on the 12th of april
a lot of these major questions about how
free will actually be
are outstanding but it's interesting
that this is happening
in government when the rollout of the
vaccine
has gone better than they could ever
have hoped back in
january or even in february and i see in
your article you say that
both covet cases and deaths are down 95
percent
since the most recent peak down 95
and that's an even faster decline than
in israel which has done even more
vaccination than we have pretty much the
whole population
has now been uh covered there and yet
there is this almost stepping back from
the original roadmap and in your article
you say it's all because they've taken
fright
at the possibility of a mutant strain of
the vaccine
of of the virus which the vaccine won't
handle is that really what's at the
bottom of this fear of a new variant
is very much on people's minds in
whitehall ministers are concerned and
the travel task force
is concerned and we got their first
update earlier this week about how we
might resume
international travel when it's legal
again it looks like we're going back to
the traffic light system or the
countries that you can visit
the summer and for the foreseeable
future without having to quarantine when
you get back
either at home or in a hotel will be
countries depending on
vaccination status infection rates and
also whether or not officials think they
are vulnerable
to a new variant now the idea of
something new coming in
and wiping out our vaccine progress is
obviously terrifying
the difficulty in crafting public policy
is that it's based on a hypothetical
so far thankfully we have not seen a
variant that can undermine our vaccines
especially in those
crucial areas of preventing
hospitalization and death
so almost by nature these rules and
regulations are going to be indefinite
because you're planning for something
that might happen in the future not
necessarily based
on the facts as they are now so when we
can travel again
it's certainly not going to be normal
and i don't think it's going to be for
quite some time
it's interesting that from the prime
minister down the the the emphasis from
government is
almost undermining their own strategy
the vaccine is not a hundred percent
effective uh but as you point out no
vaccine is really a hundred percent
effective and when it comes to um
deaths and even serious illness this
vaccine pretty much is
a hundred percent uh effective do they
do they really know what they're doing
so i think this is one of the most
concerning areas is that what we're told
constantly seems to change matt hancock
told the spectator magazine in january
that he would be crying freedom once the
most vulnerable were vaccinated
grant shap said he would be on the
barricades to restore our freedoms
around a similar timeline that hasn't
happened
the prime minister said that we would be
open by easter because of the job
success at the end of last year
that hasn't happened but now something
even more worrying is happening it's not
just that they're pushing back this
timeline
we're told actually vaccines aren't the
full answer
and i do think that boris johnson and
his officials sometimes come dangerously
close to talking down these vaccines
as you say andrew the fact that they're
not 100 effective
is is really not the point nobody in
their wildest dreams thought we would
get
a jab that had 100 efficacy that pfizer
is thought to be around 94 95 percent
effective that ostrich astrazeneca is
very good and that they're preventing
against severe hospitalization and death
is a huge success it's a miracle frankly
that we have
multiple jobs that are as good as they
are
and so if that isn't going to be what
restores liberty
and now they're talking about the return
of operation moonshot which was
estimated last year to be a 100 billion
pound project
we're going to be doing mass testing on
top of the vaccines but perhaps even
that isn't enough
we're going to have to have vaccine
passports potentially when does it
end and when can the public really see
life um
being not just back to normal but their
decisions their choices their lifestyles
being their own again
as opposed to what the state is saying
they're allowed to do it's
it's this shift in power that liberty is
now somehow conditional
and and i think that's um what the cover
piece is
is trying to look at this week just how
far down this rabbit hole do we want to
go before we say
enough is enough and government needs to
be transparent about criteria
and deadlines what they're actually
trying to achieve
you point out in the article how michael
golf ruled out
vaccine passports in december that met
hancock
he came out against them in january and
mr zahawi the vaccine minister said
there were no plans
uh to do so um where are we now with
vaccine passports
so these cova certificates as the prime
minister likes to refer to them but
their
vaccine passports are bioidentity cards
are
very much being considered the official
report that we got this week on the
status of the review
means that they are being considered for
a whole host of areas
not just around mass events but
potentially to be in hospitality
as well and we don't know the details
about how they would work yet although
we do know that you wouldn't necessarily
have to have your vaccine
to have one you could potentially have a
negative copper test
or a test proving that you had coveted
at some point within a certain manner of
months
to suggest that you also have antibodies
the idea here is that it wouldn't be
fair to roll it out
if some people had had the jab and
others hadn't been offered it yet
especially because those people are
young people at the moment the under 50s
who haven't been offered the jab
they are much less likely to die if this
virus or get severely ill and so
there would be an imbalance there but i
think many will be asking
is it fair at all number one do you have
promised that this wasn't a
consideration
and now to be very actively looking at
how they might bring it in
and number two it seems like a very
short-term tactic to hand away that kind
of liberty and personal data especially
when they're saying
that vaccine passports wouldn't come
online until the summer
at least they're not coming online for
the 12th of april or on the 17th of may
when indoor hospitality reopens and
hopefully we can see more people inside
they're suggesting they'll come online
when we're supposedly free
and i think the idea of flashing your
uh vaccine passport um to a private pub
landlord or whoever to get into an
establishment there is even talk of
face scanning and in order to access
things that we're told we're free to do
won't quite add up to people
there's no talk of when vaccine
passports were first discussed it was
you would have to have some
documentation to show that you had been
vaccinated probably
had both jabs but now i see government
talking you've touched on
of biosecurity cards
which seem to be a lot more than just a
a bit of paper or an app that says
you've been vaccinated
is the government seriously thinking of
complicating things by going down this
line
so the prime minister was loath to call
them anything but
kovitz data certification at the press
conference on monday
he didn't want to call them vaccine past
parts certainly not bio security cards
and surely the reason is one of the
reasons we can suspect is is because the
prime minister spent his career
um adamantly opposed to such things he
once said that if he were asked to
produce an identity card he would rip it
up and eat it
in front of the state official that
asked him to do so and if you get this
week's
copy of the spectator we have assembled
quite a few quotes from the prime
minister
opposed to id cards so i imagine it's
very difficult for him
to be the person who now might be
ushering them in to society
but we can't feel too bad for him
because at the end of the day
he is the person in charge and he's the
one who makes the calls
now maybe he's changed his mind maybe he
thinks that they would be useful now
if so it is not being communicated to
the public it is not at all transparent
what data or ideas are backing up this
idea because as you've mentioned
throughout our chat here andrew all of
the data is pointing in a really
positive direction the percentage of
people who have antibodies
across the uk is now estimated to be
over 50
and it's just climbing because of our
huge vaccine success
and i think a lot of this can undermine
trust if you're not honest with people
about your real
intentions that nhs app that we were
asked to download last year and sold
on the premise that we would help track
and trace people who had the virus in
their contacts but that information
would be completely private
only you and you alone would see it that
app is now being talked about
as this new mechanism for vaccine
passports not only is the data not
private you're you're
sharing it but you're also with the
venues and establishments you want to go
into but
you're now uploading quite private
health data into it you know that is a
far cry from where we were
just months ago now i know a lot of
people out there won't have my
reservations they'll be completely on
board with something like this because
they think it will be a good mechanism
to help us get our freedoms back
but we need to have this very robust
debate at the moment these decisions are
being made
by committee in reviews this is i think
a fundamental principle that could
change the way
we operate for months and potentially
years to come
and we might start to see that debate
the labour party is
for the first time in this pandemic
really starting to push back it seems on
this
point alone but you know we need to have
this discussion they may approve them in
the end they may not
but we need to be told exactly what
their purpose is and why they think now
at this point of the pandemic they're
necessary and then we can
approve or criticize let me bring in now
jamie
in joko goodwin he's the chief executive
of uk music it's an
umbrella organization representing the
british
music industry jamie welcome to
spectator tv
um what is your attitude towards vaccine
passports would that help you
reopen your businesses for the past
year since march last year it's been
prohibited by law to have mass events at
capacity
um that's a huge impact on our industry
and the challenge for us
uh for the past six months or so has
been we can either put our heads under
the sand and wait for this whole thing
to go away
or we can look at different means and
mechanisms by which we could be having
events again vibing safely
so that's been looking at things like
ventilation better working guidance
testing but also looking at things like
certification
i think it's really important that we
actually clarify what we're talking
about here because there's been a lot of
cross purposes about this debate is this
a vaccine passport to just prove that
you've had a vaccine now protected
or is it about certifying and
certification to show that you are at
less risk of transmission
i'm really compelled by the argument for
covert status certification
not actually because of the fact it
shows who's been protected but because
the increasing evidence that vaccines
can produce transmission
and then in conjunction with a test you
can be using it to show that spaces are
safer for social contact and
we've had a year of lockdowns and which
are
basically a london crude object to stop
uh social contact taking complaints and
spaces because government hasn't been
able to identify
who are the people who are at risk of
transmission inspires and who the people
that aren't
actually some sort of system where you
can identify who is
infectious who might be passing this
virus and who won't be
and therefore ensuring that rather than
lockdowns which mean a reduction of
liberty for 60 million people
you can be restricting those
restrictions to the people who are
actually infectious
seems to me to be good from a public
health point of view sensible for the
large events and
settings like nightclubs music venues
and mass events which have been able to
operate for the last year
but also importantly would hopefully
reduce the possibility that you get hit
with a future wave in the future and
have to lock down again at some point in
the future
kate what'd you say to that well i think
if we lived in a world where none of the
vaccines had been successful and the
only way to
get back to some kind of normality were
through say mass testing
uh the idea of a coveted passport a
vaccine
not a fasting passport in that
circumstance but some kind of passport
to show your copic status as jamie says
might be a pragmatic one i think there's
still many ethical issues with it i'm
not sure i would
be able to support it but i think the
argument would be stronger
what's strange to me is that thankfully
we don't live in that world
we live in a world where we have
successful vaccines the uk is on the top
five countries for rate of vaccination
and it's the country where the most
number of adults want to take the
vaccine
there really should be no reason because
these vaccines work
by the time we get to the summer that we
would be looking at bringing in
something like a vaccine passport
when the data is on our side and when
the vaccines are on our side
and i worry about a short-termist look
at freedom you know well if we have this
vaccine passport we can get back to
normal
and and what we might be sacrificing in
terms of the long term
once this framework comes in this
apparatus comes in
what will government use it for they
already haven't been on us about their
plans to bring it in in the first place
and we don't know who will be in power
in five ten years time we don't know
what the circumstances will be
if we create this now under these
emergency scenarios even though we're
really moving in the right direction
i fear what it means for future freedom
not just freedom this summer
yeah so actually i'd view this as a
long-term strategy rather than just a
kind of short term as one
um this shouldn't be seen as something
that's gonna be brought in for good or
permanently
but having this as a mechanism which can
either be turned on or off depending on
where you're in a pandemic state
seems to me to be completely sensible um
it there
there does seem to be a well i
completely agree with kate that if we
have a vaccine that is going to work
permanently isn't going to be affected
by a new variant then this wouldn't be
necessary and we could just open up
but the worry seems to be as with all
other viruses
increased transmission increases the
likelihood of a mutation
and you find yourself with the vats with
a virus and a variant that is going to
be virus-resistant this is what happens
with flu it's why every year you have to
update your flu vaccines and develop new
flu vaccines
and when you've got a virus it's as
transmissible as coveted
increased transmission makes that much
more likely so i see this as a means of
mechanism of
trying to reduce transmission in a way
that isn't again not doing it through
lockdowns
not doing it through increased and
sometimes quite draconian restrictions
by doing it in a way where you can have
normal life happening but with certain
mitigations whether
things like mask wearing whether that's
things like code certification
but i think it's also really important
not just for now but for future
pandemics
we're living in an age where if you look
at loss of biodiversity increasing
international travel what's happening
with climate change
it's not only 100 years before we hit by
the next one of these things it could be
much sooner than we think
and a strategy in the future of we're
just going to lock down for a year wait
for a vaccine and then open up
personally isn't good for industries
it's not good for individuals and it's
not good for anyone
if you can have some sort of system in
place for the future that means when you
are hit by a future pandemic you can
have a testing system you can stand up
you can have a certification system that
says rather than having to lock down
your country
for a year you can identify who's
infectious who isn't
and probably try and have much more
normal life i think if you had this sort
of certification system this time last
year
with a testing capacity and a
certification system by which you could
identify
who was going to be at risk of strenuous
virus you'd probably have been able to
go a long way without knocking down bars
without locking down hospitality without
stopping mass events
and actually be able to be doing life as
normal so i view certification not just
a sign that's important for getting out
of this pandemic
but also protects and guarding against
having to lock down in future ones as
well
so kate what jamie's arguing there is
that a version of a biosecurity card
which is
what this would almost certainly develop
into it would be a necessary
tool for future for dealing with future
pandemics and if we have it
we might avoid the kind of lockdowns
that we've had to endure
in this pandemic well i'm not just sure
he's arguing for a biosecurity card but
a biosecurity state
i mean the world that jamie just painted
is one in which liberty is never fully
restored it turns out that our lifestyle
before was
too carefree too loose that we are
always going to need to think about next
hypothetical thing that can go wrong
and we need to make sure that people are
ready to get in line
to do whatever the government asks them
to do in order to tackle that
hypothetical
if you have this certification system as
jamie says and something
else comes along whatever it may be
what's going to be the new certification
what is it this time that the state's
going to ask you to do so that you can
go to the pub so that you can go to a
mass event so that you can be free
we don't know what that future is
imagined to be
but let's hope that when it comes we
will have proper scrutiny
and debate and that people will have
some say and get to decide what they
think the right level
of risk is if we set up a system in
which
our freedoms are always conditional on
what the state has decided
is the appropriate level of risk we are
never going back to the way it was now
i think you can make that argument in
fact this is exactly the debate
that i think needs to happen over the
next few weeks and months do we want to
trade away
all of that liberty for security and you
know plenty of people will and i think
that there's an argument to make but
let's be very honest about what that
future actually looks like and let's not
call it normal let's not even call it
the new normal it would be the
introduction of a biosecurity state
in which um it wouldn't matter if the
evidence was on the government side it
would only have to be a hypothetical
it used to be the case that if
politicians wanted to infringe on your
freedom
they had to present that argument they
had to make the case
and they had to convince hearts and
minds but now we're saying that that
power is flipped
we'll only return it when you can prove
that it's safe enough to return it that
you can prove
that things won't go wrong and i think
that is the wrong place
to put the power i think that we that we
need to flip that back
uh because otherwise as said we don't
know what the future looks like in 10
years time we don't know who's in charge
we don't know how they'll want to use
this
so to bring it in um in these
circumstances i think
could in the future go badly wrong jb
final word to you
i think a lot of people may conclude
that what you are going for
is really id cards by the back door but
actually
a lot more intrusive than id cards
because they'll
contain a lot more information than tony
blair when he was arguing for id
cards ever envisaged it would be id
cards on steroids so i mean i first need
to say
completely with kate this is a debate
actually needs to be had a discussion
needs to have quite openly there's a lot
of ethical and legal regulatory issues
that people need to be talking about and
having an actual debate on
um look for the past year maybe i like
the pub too much maybe i like bars too
much but i haven't been sat there
thinking
that stuff is closed but at least i
don't have to share my search my code
with certification status
and we're living in a pandemic where
difficult decisions are having to be
taken
but the focus is having to be what can
you be doing to be able to make sure
things are safe and
not at risk of um of increased variance
and of future waves
i don't see this as a biosecurity state
we're currently living through
a world where the government is doing
1.5 million tests a day
now make sure you be using that testing
with those testing results and using
that testing capacity in a way that can
identify
how people can be kept as safe as
possible and again i don't see that as a
biosecurity state all that
sort of stuff is already happening it's
making sure that the work that's being
done
is being utilized as effectively as
possible to prevent the threat of
um of future waves but also um to return
to the liberties i think lots of us have
missed over
the past year but i completely agree
it's a debate that i think we should be
having and
very very well well it's a debate we've
had here in spectator tv and we'll come
back to it
jamie and joko godwin uh chief executive
of uk
music thanks for being with us today and
kate andrews of the spectator
thank you as as well now remember if you
enjoy what we do here at spectator
tv why not take out a subscription to
the spectator magazine itself
just google spectator gin to subscribe
for
one pound a week and a free bottle of
spectator gin with it what's
not to like about that now some argue
that the
evidence of britain's irredeemably
racist past can be found
in our historical statutes a road statue
in oxford for example
has been under the spotlight for some
time now it's still there
so far but slave owner edward colston
was toppled
at the height of the black life's uh
mata protest
in bristol last summer the government's
response has been a so-called retain
and explain policy in other words
wax and plaques on controversial
statutes to educate the passerby but
keep the monuments in place sounds a
compromise sounds good well
spectator contributor alexander pelling
bruce argues against it
in this week's issue he joins spectator
tv now uh
alexander welcome to the program thank
you for your uh
article in the spectator this week let
me start
with the intriguing example i think so
far you say
the only example of retain and explain
in action in the united kingdom which is
in edinburgh
it's uh involves henry dundas
a very famous historical scottish figure
who became
lord melville uh and because
although as i understand it he had
managed to establish that under scottish
law slavery would be illegal
he inserted in the legislation to
abolish slavery
the word gradual and for that
there has to be an explanatory uh
plaque on the statue have i got it right
tell us what happened in edinburgh
yes that is essentially right um so the
contention
is that he inserted this this word
gradual
and the anti-dundas activists say
that therefore this delayed abolition
and therefore resulted in the the
transportation
and death of 500 000 slaves
which otherwise would not have happened
and
this i think is a gross distortion
because first of all
it's attributing causation direct
causation where
i think that is not applicable um but
also
on the historical fact of it is that by
inserting that word
a good interpretation is that he
actually
ensured um the passage of the act
um because otherwise for the
anti-abolitionist
movement having not having that word
would be too strong
but it was interesting that you you
point out that
edinburgh city council did not bring in
respected historians to decide
what of anything should be on uh uh a
plaque explaining more about henry
dundas
that they they instead they use somebody
called jeff palmer who is basically
he's got i think previous record of
being pretty anti-dundas and
there's also a human rights activist
he's not a as i understand it
a historian of this period that would
bring expertise to the issue is that
right
that is exactly right and he's been on a
you know the anti-dundas hunt you know
for many years
actually this this this whole debate
over
over dundas and the melville monument
goes back a number of years now
and initially edinburgh city council um
proposed
a you know a proper commission made up
of
balanced views and different historians
to examine this issue
and what happened was they didn't come
to a settled conclusion
and so the matter was sort of parked
then you had the black lives matter
protest
last year and in within three days
after that they'd hastily assembled a
new commission with jeff
palmer they got rid of the other
historians that they had before
and then they quickly settled on on this
wording
so there was no proper process there was
no diligence there was no
um establishing you know the total facts
on this and coming to a kind of settled
uh view um that would be academically
respectable
um this is also you you can see this uh
for example with other commissions that
have been set up
um most notably uh sadiq khan's
uh um uh
diversity in the public realm commission
um
you know the the makeup of it is
populated by
by these sort of uh race relations
activists and people who have already
actually
said um expressed a view uh on these
matters
before the inquiry actually takes place
it also happened with the rhodes
commission in oxford
where there were
there was not enough sort of historical
weight and expertise
what should be done though with someone
say take the colson statue which was
brought down and dumped in the harbor by
kind of mob
action but we're talking about a man
who as i understand it was regarded at
the time
in bristol as something of a
philanthropist but
had undoubtedly made his money out of
slavery
and had i think been a slave owner or
trader and that's where his money came
from
the fact that he became a philanthropist
is nevertheless
surely clouded by where the money comes
from
i mean if i was part of the brink's mat
robbery and then used some of that to be
a philanthropist
it would surely rather tarnish my
reputation as a
philanthropist what should be done with
a statue like that
well remember remember the old saying
from uh emperor
he used public funds to uh set up sewers
i think
in uh in rome um you know money doesn't
stink
it's i don't i'm not sure that the money
the provenance of the money actually is
the overriding factor
in these things i think it's what the
the the money is used for
um by way of comparison you see this
with museums when
they are sponsored by sort of
petrochemical companies like bp
and and whatever the money is still
being used to a good cause it's
a question in that context is a question
of
are there uh sort of quid pro pros are
there
um is that company benefiting in sort of
a way that's not in the public interest
in the colston case um in the colston
case we have a plane flying over
it i hope i heard that but carry on
struggle through
in the in the colston case um of course
the the the the his
he was a great benefactor um to the city
and that is why
the statue was was raised um by public
subscription
um in bristol so the the point i'm
trying to make here is
if we are going to get into into
you know if we're going to establish
this premise that um
whatever uh you know any supposed uh
moral flaw or wrongdoing you know for
example david olisoga who i think is
actually one of the
more serious decolonizing historians you
know he said
in an interview you know channel 4 with
jon snow
um you know i don't think we should be
having memorials
and statues that legitimize and validate
you know the lives of people who've done
terrible things
um i think it's inappropriate well
that's a rather sort of banal school
mastery way of putting it i think
and and the problem here is these
statues
are not established
as testaments of of character if that
were the case we would have statues you
know
to to volunteers you know to to to civil
servants perhaps you know to
to uh to saints and priests or maybe not
all priests but anyway
um they are they are there because
that individual has done some public
good or has it has
is being recognized for a particular set
of public achievements
so this whole retain and explain
approach completely transforms
the purpose of a statute and i think
that in itself is why it might be
misguided
all right alexander palin bruce it's a
fascinating article
and we'll see how far the government
gets with its retain and explain
uh policy and also see what kind of
rules it may
put around that to deal with what
happened to henry dundas
in edinburgh thanks for the article
thanks for joining us on spectator
tv now the weeks are counting down
to may's holyrood elections in scotland
uh
and a surprise electoral force a couple
of weeks ago joined the fray alex simon
has established his own party
coded alba that's not quite the correct
pronunciation and he's been taking snp
defectors from
the first day so what's his purpose what
does it hope to achieve
uh let's speak to one of those defectors
kenny mccaskill he was the
snp mp for easter lothian
and he joins us now welcome to spectator
tv kenny mccaskill
thank you i was enjoying the discussion
on dundas
uh it was very interesting i agree the
the author also mentions the hunterian
museum in the university of glasgow
which is one of the finest
university museums uh in the united
kingdom it now has
what's called a curator of discomfort
i'm not quite sure what that is
but it's got one uh but i didn't get on
to that anyway back to you
and the elections why have you
left a party which is led by
the most popular politician in scotland
uh to join one whose leader alex salmond
is as unpopular in scotland as boris
johnson
well i think this is the necessary
opportunity it's necessary because the
threat we're facing in terms of what
happens post pandemic
in terms of increased austerity and
there's the opportunity there
by an independent super majority so
fundamentally it's about delivering an
independent super majority within the
scottish parliament
but equally be fair to say that there
had been issues within the smp so
i depart in reasonable terms because i
had many more good years and still agree
with much
but there were issues that took me to go
but fundamentally it's about what we can
do
and i think what we can say is we've
already changed what was meant to be a
rather sleepy election
where independence was just simply going
to be rhetorical
and it was a question of would the snp
get a majority and who would come second
with independence now being front and
center of the debate
uh if you get this super majority you
you want a fast track referendum
is that right how how quickly would you
want a second referendum
no what we're saying is it changes first
of all the whole nature of the debate
uh i know the snp position is the
thought that johnson would blink we
don't necessarily
adhere to that that this view that he'll
change his position on the section 30
orders that technology is
i think what we're seeking to do is to
ensure that after the 6th of may
it's not a scottish government asking a
westminster prime minister
it's in fact the scottish parliament
representing scottish
democracy that is demanding the right
for self-determination
that could be a referendum if they're
prepared to accede to it there are other
ways it can be looked at in terms of
court actions international steps and
indeed just public
representation whether in demonstrations
as and when that's allowed
but how quickly if you get this super
majority how quickly would you like the
referendum
well we want to move towards scotland
getting the necessary powers as soon as
possible
whether that's by way of a referendum uh
that will have to be discussed because
so far that's not an option being
allowed and therefore
what other way could scotland get
independence other than a referendum
well you could have negotiations between
the parliaments ultimately you're
correct
almost invariably they have to be put to
the people in a
in a referendum that happens it's
happened in slovakia it happened in
ireland over a century ago
but you could have the discussions about
where you're going rather than having a
vote on the the the concept initially so
there's a whole array of opportunities
that we'd have to come about but if the
scottish parliament is representing the
democratic will of the scottish people
which is
for independence then i think that
changes the whole dynamic the same as
alba has changed the dynamic of the
electoral debate
but the scottish people on may are not
electing a parliament for independence
they're electing a parliament to run
their schools and their hospitals
and their transport that's uh if you
look at opinion polling
a second referendum comes way down the
list compared to hospitals and schools
the scottish people have been denied a
second referendum because boris
johnson's made it clear that he's not
prepared to do it
it's got scottish vaginal party and
indeed the parliament have voted for a
referendum and have supported that
and yet it's been rejected in that
circumstance we see it as perfectly
legitimate to use the hollywood
elections
as the means of giving our people a form
of plebiscite
and that's why on the list vote they can
vote for alba which is a vote for an
independent super majority they're under
no doubt what they're looking for
exactly the same as george galloway as
putting forward a party
so as i say i think in the denial of
democracy by
a refusal of a section 30 order we've
opened up the
requirement to use the hollywood
elections as a plan b
as some of my colleagues used to talk
about but back in 2017 uh just after the
general election and the snp
fought that general election on a second
referendum
uh you wrote that there was quote no
credible platform on which to win
another referendum
and that people were tired of referenda
that was only four years ago what's
changed
well i think one of the reasons i've
gone to alba is that there has been a
lack of preparation amongst the
leadership of the snp
action does have to be taken on
discussing borders and discussing
currency and discussing pensions
issues that we knew were difficult in
2014 if
issues that have now transformed because
of brexit so uh
the groundwork has to be laid alba will
be doing that and the parliament can
ensure that
so that was a position taken with regard
to the snp
and equally it would also be fair to say
that the brexit uh
the brexit deal that has been struck is
causing mayhem in the economy in
scotland in my own constituency in
particular
the threats to our health and social
services faced by trade deals that are
coming down the line with the usa
the attacks upon our parliament through
the internal market bill
all of these things mean that the ground
has changed and now is the time for
scotland to defend itself
all right well four years ago that you
wrote that doubts on the currency and on
pensions as two examples have not been
answered or assuaged so
in four years do you not have the answer
what currency would an independent
scotland use
well we're making it clear that we'll
move towards our own currency initially
we have to use sterling that is
perfectly possible governor
mark carney acknowledged that before he
retired
there won't be a currency union that was
the position taken by
george osborne but there can be use of
sterling but we'll move as soon as we
can towards the scottish country that's
uh
so you would use a form of
sterlingization as it's called you
wouldn't be part of monetary union
but you would still use sterling which
you would have
no right to print or to set interest
rates
then you wouldn't have a central bank as
a bank of last resort because it
wouldn't be able to create money
how long would you be in that position
well i'd be for a shortest period of
time as is possible that's something
that has to be discussed both within our
party democracy and fundamentally by
those negotiating
but i think you know there were there
was a plan put forward by the
scottish national party through the
growth commission that was for some
considerable period of time
that is unacceptable it has to be in a
reasonable time scale it has to be
quite speedy but the precise tab i don't
think will be for me it will be for
those representing the scottish
government and speaking on behalf of the
scottish parliament
but it'll have to be speedier and do you
accept
that if there was a new currency to be
launched
that you would have to pay in your
interest rates a risk premium because
this would be a new currency
with no track record for a country with
a massive
budget deficit and a bounce of payments
deficit you'd have to pay a lot
to borrow wouldn't you well these
these things have been changing and
evolving there are issues and challenges
that we face exactly the same as those
issues and challenges that the united
kingdom
faces but the resources scotland faces
the position in which we are in terms of
uh being able to transition on to
independence
we're in a better position than almost
any country in the history
of being able to move out so there are
challenges but um
yesterday would move out with a deficit
about ten percent of gdp
it would be the highest deficit in
europe you're proposing a new currency
that you'd have to borrow in
to finance some of that deficit i doubt
you could finance at all
so you would be paying a lot of money to
borrow to get people to lend for that
huge deficit that's not a very good
position to be
well almost every government has been
operating on a deficit other than japan
and china for many
years so it's nothing unusual and indeed
as i say i think the whole nature of the
economy that we were told was impossible
of deficit
you know the whole coronavirus crisis
across the world not simply the western
world has shown that
deficits are necessary can be managed
it's how you deal with your economy
at the present moment the scottish
economy is being damaged by the brexit
deal
news would be the biggest in europe what
currency would
the people's pensions be paid in
well these these things are arrangements
that are made they happen
you're across borders you're speaking to
me from out with you know the united
kingdom so it's something
unusual for people to be receiving
pensions payments or whatever else in
different countries in different
countries
by pensions paid in sterling which is
what it i always expected it to be
but what currency would an independent
scotland's pensions be in
well independent scotland once you moved
into the scottish country they would be
in the scottish currency
it would be depending where you're
getting your pension i will be receiving
a pension presumably from westminster
unless arrangements are made with uh
with the scottish parliament and also be
receiving a pension through the scottish
civil service
so these things are dealt with by the
individual institution depending upon
their
well you could i would suggest if you
have your own currency you could only
pay
pensions in whatever that scottish
currency was and there would always be a
risk which i think it would only be fair
to make
uh knowledgeable to the scottish people
that as a new currency
uh as the new kid on the block there
would be a risk that that
currency could depreciate substantially
against sterling couldn't wouldn't there
well there are risks in every currency
as we've seen with the with the pound
sterling which uh
uh has gone up and gone down or whatever
but you know at the end of the day
but that doesn't matter for pensions uh
kenya mccaskill you know
it may go up or down but you you're
paying for stuff
in sterling and your pensions and
sterling you would be in a situation
where you would be paying the pensions
in local currency
and against sterling it could be
substantially devalued
but the problem with the scottish
economy at the present moment is we
don't have the levers of power
our economy is underperforming uh you
know i grew up in the 60s a time when
oil was discovered in scotland and in
norway
scotland has been left lagging way
behind as norway has motored on
the economy of the republic of ireland
has motored beyond not simply northern
ireland but scotland with a higher
quality of life and standard of living
that's because these countries have been
able to decide their own future to take
decisions to benefit from their own
natural
assets and so yes of course you're
correct there are issues and challenges
that we face
but equally there are opportunities
because the tragedy for scotland andrew
isn't how bad things are for the likes
of me because life's quite
good for me i have to say but tragically
it's not good for so many more scotland
should be doing so much better we are
underperforming
that's ultimately the responsibility of
westminster that has been in charge of
the economic levers of power
why are you so victorious about
nicola sturgeon in july 2020 you
described her as a
narcissistic sociopath uh no i didn't
in july 20 2020 you were criticized for
liking
you were liking a tweet i'm sorry i
corrected but you liked to tweet
calling her a narcissistic sociopath
well that was a
that was a friend who had put the tweet
out it wasn't my words and i was simply
uh
uh it was in relationship to
the person i knew so you you
i think we all retweet things and you
know social media
has a downside i'm currently getting a
lot of uh traffic in as you can imagine
uh and we come for that i have to
shoulder shoulder with nicola sturgeon
and with alex hammond has stood on the
platform with them together on
referendum i disagree with actions that
nicola has taken but equally i respect
the contributions she has made when i
served in cabinet with her
and indeed her continued contribution in
the scottish government but we disagree
on various issues and on that basis
i have gone into the alba party you
accused her of treating voters with
contempt
i don't know the context that you're
you're referring to that i mean i may
have
i may have used those words but i think
you would require to tell me just what
what the context of the article was
because it'll be one reference to
something
right well you it was a reference to a
number of things that she
had been doing you accused her of of the
snp
had become under her a stalinist uh
strict presbyterian sect
and that's why i've chosen the language
i mean political disagreement i can
understand but this is the
woman who has become you know the
best-known politician in scotland the
most formidable politician in scotland
uh who leads a government that is almost
certainly to be re-elected in may in
some form
and yet your language about her is it's
almost as if you were
talking in europe like about the tories
well
i think if you will recall that uh i was
out of politics for a while i was a
columnist
as you yourself are and as your
colleagues are on the spectator
you use language that you wouldn't
necessarily perhaps use when you're an
elected politician
uh to describe things i as i say have
the highest respect for nicholas
sturgeon i disagree
with her on how she has been running the
operation the scottish national party
it's simply unacceptable that her
husband is the chief executive i've
argued that
even you know when i was still a an msp
i i think there are issues and where
they've gone and women's rights that i
fundamentally disagree with and have
written about in the paper today because
i think
there are issues whether it's in unisex
toilets or the safety and security of
staff and women prisoners in the women's
prison estate
that the snp has made big mistakes on
but i recognize her commitment to
independence i recognize her
contribution
and that's why both alex sam and myself
and every member of alba will be
happy to stand shoulder to shoulder with
her and every other member of the snp
on the wider common cause if there is
not a majority of msps
after the election who who stood on an
independence
manifesto if there's not a majority
what then happens to a second referendum
well it's exactly the same there is a
majority it depends upon
at the present moment until the snp are
prepared to change their position then
we're dependent upon
boris johnson's uh veto we think that
delivering an independence majority
changes the whole dynamic of the debate
and opens up that i understand that and
that's
the always the result detroit of alba i
understand that
but if there isn't a majority of msps
for independence
after may what happens to a second
referendum i believe
that there will be but uh the position
the position of alban indeed the
position i always subscribed to in the
snp andrew was that i want independence
but also
as well as independence i want scotland
to be the best it can be
so whilst you're in devolution then you
have to make sure that the scotland that
you seek
uh is as good as it can be and indeed if
the people of scotland whatever to
decide that they ultimately didn't want
independence then it would still be my
obligation in my home to
home country to make sure that this is
the best country that it can be
there are issues you know that we have
to address in scotland
not all of which i fully accept can be
laid at the bear of london
we have to up our game across a whole
swathe of areas
but the only people who are going to do
that the only people who will prioritize
that are
the scots and the through their elected
representatives
the turnout at scottish elections is not
that
impressive if it was under 50 percent
if turnout was below 50 in may
where would that leave your mandate well
i
i think the mandate would still exist
because you take elections
in terms of what is delivered into the
outcome uh there are challenges in this
election which is why you know postal
ballots are
increasingly being pushed even if the
scots hadn't voted
that would undermine your mandate even
if you were to win a super majority no
i'm not going you know i'm not going to
deny i want as big a turnout as possible
and equally fair to say
that i think those in the more
challenged areas where voting is perhaps
less uh the norm are also more likely to
vote for us so there's an imperative for
us to actually try and ensure that and
we will be
doing that because i think what was
clear was in the independence referendum
the turnout was higher in that
referendum than it has been in any
uh hollywood election before or after
that tends to be the situation in
referenda that do encourage
huge turnouts and wider issues so i
think the turnout here will be
that substantial will be significant
because we've made this on the
constitution
there's a final question ian blackford
who who leads the
smp parliamentary delegation in
westminster in the house of commons
he said of your defection that you had
become an increasing embarrassment to
the snp
and that your departure was somewhat of
a relief
as people who are united by a common
cause that doesn't
sound like solidarity to me well i think
that's uh
that's what ian blackford to comment on
he made similar curtic and caustic
remarks against joanna cherry who
remains
in the snp i think that's something ian
blackford should reflect upon
i'm not going to criticize him on air
i've disagreed with them on issues but
equally again as with nicola sturgeon
on the cause of independence i will
continue to work with them as i always
have in the past
and uh i just hope that you will reflect
and learn from that
kevin mccaskill i know election
campaigns are a busy time
so we're grateful to you for giving us
your time here
on spectator tv thank you now
that's it for this week thanks to all of
our guests and uh to our
very special sponsor
charles stanley the sponsor of the week
in 50 minutes is one of the uk's leading
wealth management firms
charles stanley one of the oldest firms
on the london stock exchange
finally a reminder to pick up that
bottle of spectator gin it's worth 30
pounds
but it's free to you if you sign up to
subscribe to the spectator at spectator
dot co
dot uk tv offer
or if you want to make it simple just
google spectator gin and you'll find
your way
to a subscription and the gin as always
send any thoughts you have
to spectator tv at spectator dot co dot
uk and join us again next week bye bye
[Music]
you